that's not the plan
so you obviously have been in
relationships with uh women who you've
started their rap careers obviously
Christians just performed the other
night I saw her she fell I mean I hope
she's all right
um
how did you start rapping like did you
convince her or what like
okay so um
one day I just came I walked in the
house and she was like
let me try it like okay he didn't just
walk in we were we were drinking it
wasn't like it was just like hey how you
doing okay
no I mean yeah he came over one day we
was drinking and I was just like put me
in like let's go and then he was like
for real I'm like yeah let's see like
how it goes how long ago was that
probably like a month ago so a month ago
so yeah it was like recently so for you
do you kind of see like the like okay
because we can't like the elephant in
the room is krishan's a star right she's
huge and you I mean that's a lot to do
with you obviously right do you see that
and say hey I could do that but I could
do it better
I mean there's no traffic if you're in
your own lane like I'm not really like
in a competition with nobody
stop that [__]
no I'm I'm just saying I'm not in a
company with nobody it wasn't like that
at all I don't know she's always been a
fan of musical rapper right I like
artists but she never like told me give
me so it was like when I heard it I was
like so it's like the way she was like
say if I'm the dope man right I'm never
gonna like insist on you getting in the
game and selling dope but if you come to
me like yeah man I want to get some
money I want to sell something
here yeah
here take this dough let me see what you
do today so what's that kind of like I
was like okay I was surprised when she
asked me I was like oh yeah did you help
her write the song Stewie did you help
her with some of the pen no no she wrote
the whole song you wrote everything
everything
yo she looked away right now like
it's true I mean I get you know I mean
he obviously helped me obviously yeah I
mean yeah some of it came from like
giving him ideas of where to go I'm more
just an engineering no a r type just
like you know
I do music so you know I know where
people are what they want to hear yeah
so I was just like I'm just coaching
around that but as far as the lyrics
she wrote all the lyrics okay we got I'm
always trying to figure out the Dynamics
of your love life blue because it is
very yeah from week to week
I don't know what they're saying I saw
you just where you just performed at the
uh the fight that that was a wild that I
mean the whole night that was a wild
night but but but again like you perform
with Chris uh obviously you're you're
with your your girl right here are you
guys in a relationship are you guys
what's happening here like what's the
status of blue like what are you doing
are we are depending on what week it is
yeah I think so
it's business it's like I'd rather get
money with somebody
than get money by myself you have to
play the the point that I'm at and then
some people they want to get money by
themselves for me so it's like okay me
and rock who's getting money together
and then
you know I guess she felt the type of
way I mean I'm more in the music side
and I feel like she's more on the TV
side like she's more into this well you
guys have a team have you guys ever
showed you crazy no no but I'm saying I
only indulge in these ideas to benefit
the music for her you know I didn't do
it thinking like yeah that's that's
pretty Superstar reality TV you know I
do music so it's like okay I'm as these
opportunities come in I'm like okay yeah
we should do it it's gonna better your
music better your music more promotion
more promotion but
she kind of felt more in love with that
right so she kind of like made
relationships in that field in that lane
and you know like that's not my Lane so
right I'm not gonna try to jump into
that lane to like so yeah so I just had
to like take a step back and let her
pursue that
but Jaden she's doing we doing just
music like you know we're going to take
a different route and it's gonna be a
different Lane it's gonna be a different
kind of a whole different how many songs
do you have today just the one just the
one yeah it's only been like two days I
don't say it's been quick because like
if you just decide you want to rap a
month ago oh yeah yeah no we just put it
out like two days ago or so like Friday
I mean I mean how many songs do you have
that are just that you've recorded or is
this just that that was my first time
ever in the studio
[Music]
if you guys go on a double date she's
got to be like I'm Little Mermaid what
am I doing at this bowling alley with
blueface and his roster I
don't know
um lessons I learned you know from
from everything you've done everything
so I wouldn't even we wouldn't even
insist on that